[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on this Thursday August
the 10th my name is Freddie gray and I
will be your host today
on the show this week
Vladimir Putin may or may not be winning
his war against Ukraine but is he
winning the bigger spiritual war that he
is waging against the West Lionel
Shriver has written about that subject
in the magazine this week and I'll be
talking to her as well as the writer Rob
Henderson
and speaking of spiritual Wars the cover
of The Spectator this week here it is
um is about the war on Countryside
Pursuits William Moore The Spectators
William Moore has written the piece and
I'll be talking to him about the ongoing
lawfare against hunting shooting and
fishing
and then we will turn our attentions
towards America and talk about the
bubbling story that is Hunter Biden and
his dodgy past I'll be talking to Ben
schreckinger of Politico about that
ongoing scandal
and then we will come back to Britain
and ask the important question what is
the matter with e-bikes Peter Hitchens
has written a tirade against electric
bikes and a bit against e-scooters as
well
um and he'll be joined by Henry Mance
who's an e-bike fan uh and Peter's been
quite rude about Henry so we'll have to
see what those two ABS say to each other
and finally
we're going to talk about sourdough
Julie bindle who normally writes about
feminism and very important topics has
written an extremely popular piece on
The Spectators website about how much
she dislikes sourdough bread I'm a bit
of a Sourdough fan so um stay tuned for
that Clash
but before we get going I'd like to give
you a quick reminder to subscribe to our
YouTube channel you will not regret
subscribing to our YouTube channel to do
that you click the Subscribe button at
the bottom of your screen and also tap
the Bell icon to make sure you get
reminders and never ever miss an episode
now Vladimir Putin is selling his war in
Russia as a war just not against the
Ukraine but against a spiritually
decadent and bankrupt West a western
world that we'll live in that is
obsessed with
gender debates the denial of biological
reality
and drag queens and lgbtq issues and so
on
Lionel Shriver our brilliant columnist
has a column in this week where she says
the problem here is that Vladimir Putin
has a point
uh Lionel joins me now alongside the
writer Rob Henderson
Lionel
why does Vladimir Putin have a point
uh well
with things that are in the big picture
small and um so it's distracting us from
solving bigger problems uh
but I would also maintain that something
like the
transgender movement is
significant it doesn't pertain to that
many people although it does affect the
way our children are being educated
its significance really has to do with
the
denial of reality and when you start
denying reality uh well there's no
natural limit is there
um
I mean if I were this if I were the
former Soviets
um I couldn't come up with anything
better than the package of obsessions
that we've come up with
and in the column I mean I which I have
to admit is something of a rant
um it's
set of
um
of of
positions and attitudes that really come
up come down to uh a self-dislike a kind
of burgeoning fifth column within the
West that is
destroying itself and you know one of
honestly one of those elements is the
obsession with Net Zero which uh is
looking as if it's going to be quite a
minority
um
uh Obsession
especially when it comes down to
actually doing something about it rather
than talking talk is cheap
but if only the West really gets on
board even assuming that all the the
climate change
uh activists are are correct you know
it's just all the sacrifice is not going
to make any difference and
and again you know
if the Russians
were to come up with uh an ideology that
would be perfectly designed to
impede and even defeat the West this is
perfect you know we we're busy trying to
convert to a technology we don't even
have yet really and to uh you know make
everything electric before we actually
have the means of generating that
electricity it's completely insensible
and 84 percent of the uh of the world's
energy is still
based on fossil fuels and we're acting
as if you know virtually tomorrow we can
live without them
um
just across the board you know uh
Freddie you sent me a really interesting
clip of uh uh
Soviet dissident
who defected and
talking about how the KGB primarily uh
tries to had been trying to subvert the
U.S not through spying but through
um ideological corruption
and it's almost as if that's what
they've been doing I mean
I I feel as if you know I I calling it
woke now is insufficient we're all sick
of the word anyway
um and it's just too small and Too Cute
this is something deep and terrible I
mean this whole thing of having rejected
meritocracy and and now awarding uh
all kinds of positions to people just
because of what race or sex or sexual uh
orientation they have I mean that's that
is a recipe for self-destruction
yes and Robert's not just uh Russia is
it I mean a lot of other countries are
starting to see the West uh America and
its allies in this way
um China does to a certain extent the
bric countries do and in fact a lot of
these countries in their various
International conferences and so on talk
about a geopolitical Tipping Point
um where American hegemony is coming to
an end and we're moving into a
multilateral world
and it's obvious to them
that uh the culture wars if you like are
a sign of
um Western weakness
um and indeed that they may they may
even be trying at some level to stoke it
have you seen any any evidence of of
other countries trying to stoke the
culture wars in order to prove that the
West is in Decline
uh sure I mean there have been some
interesting pieces uh especially during
the the riots and the demonstrations of
2020 of uh China developing Bots and
hiring individuals to Post online on
social media accounts to stoke uh
contentious debate and and to troll
people and to essentially uh sort of
cultivate hostility and animosity uh
between Americans and this is this is in
their interest to do so I mean one of
the things that Lionel pointed out in
her column uh which I which I found
fascinating uh was the the body
positivity point I mean this is
something that I this is this has been
this finding has been shown uh in in
multiple Outlets the New York Times
recently covered this but I'm still
shocked at how little attention it is
received which is that the Pentagon
recently really released a survey
showing that eight out of ten Young
Americans are ineligible to enlist in
the military primarily due to issues of
obesity physical and mental health
issues Criminal records and so on so if
80 percent of young people aren't
eligible to enlist I mean that in itself
shows a sort of significant cultural
Decline and we seem to not be so
interested in what's going on with with
young people uh if we are to go to and
to enter some kind of conflict with
Russia or any other country whether to
support Ukraine or or anyone else
um it seems that we should be
focusing on what has happened uh to
young people and instead we'd rather
talk about body positivity and some of
the other issues that Lyle points out
Lionel I was speaking to uh a an admiral
in the French navy recently who was
quite concerned he wasn't a sort of
right-wing lunatic by any means but he
was quite concerned about young people
in France and he talked about French
people he talked about British people
and Americans too and a lack of
willingness if it came to to actually
fight
um do you think this Taps into what
we're talking about here that Western
people have sort of given up on our own
culture or on what we are meant to
believe in
when the war in Ukraine started there
were some polls done of Americans anyway
and whether or not they would fight for
their country and the Figures were
appalling and very few
um
and that's what we're talking about it
kind of
this package
of of
distractions as well as
uh
self-doubting attitudes
there was a recent if I can just say
there was a recent finding from Gene
twangy's new book Generations she
outlines the sort of characteristic
differences of the generations in the
U.S and when shocking finding that she
pointed out and I wrote about this in
the Free Press which is uh something
like 47 of gen z uh young adults say
that the that America's Founders are
more accurately described as villains
rather than Heroes now I know that uh
you know if you're talking to British
people maybe they have some some
interesting thoughts about that but at
least you know Young Americans thinking
that the founders of their own country
you know nearly half of Young Americans
viewing their the founders of their own
country this way I think this is
indicative of something clearly going
wrong with with youth
yeah there's it's a deep demoralization
and
you can trace it back
a couple of generations it's been going
on for a long time but rather than just
run its course it seems to be gathering
Steam and
it's deadly uh
on it on every level and I and I think
that
there's very you know there's very
little substitute to substitute for it
uh in a positive way you know all of the
passions are negative uh they're all
filled with Dread uh I don't even think
that there is a
a
consuming
Vivid vision of a an ideal future that
is powering younger people you know the
a utopianism or uh where we're all going
to be equal and there will be no more
racism and and there is no there are no
gender there's no gender roles and we're
all just ourselves I mean you can kind
of put together that picture but
basically what's
what's in these people's head as far as
I can tell is very dark very dark
nothing but dread and also of of
in eagerness to put off adulthood
and of course fighting your for your
country that's the ultimate in adulthood
uh
the weird Embrace of of
not just of mental illness itself but uh
but an eagerness to have a diagnosis of
some sort and the competition over
effectively who's weaker uh which is
what the whole victimhood thing is about
who can be weaker who can be more
oppressed and therefore more powerless
uh
I don't think all all young people are
like this I I don't
but we don't hear from the people who
aren't like this very much
yes uh brother it's good to ask you to
what extent are we just beating up
ourselves unnecessarily because uh well
there's no doubt that Vladimir Fusion
wants to stoke up uh the culturals wants
to stoke up the resentment of social
conservatives and Christians in in
Western countries uh he's not the ideal
ambassador of uh sort of the moral good
I mean it's perfectly obvious to most
Russians with a brain that hears himself
uh a corrupt and uh almost certainly
murderous figure
right well just just as sometimes good
people have bad ideas sometimes bad
people can make good points and I think
in this case in this instance uh yeah
he's he's made some astute critiques uh
often your enemies your adversaries can
be quite good at pointing out your
shortcomings and your inadequacies in
ways that friends can't or won't because
your friends have an interest in
flattering you or buttering you up or
perhaps overlooking uh some of your
flaws whereas your enemies can be very
good at pinpointing uh where you're
coming up short and in this case yeah he
has pointed out a lot of flaws that that
you know westerners themselves have been
speaking about for a long time I mean it
wouldn't surprise me if Putin himself
was sort of reading a lot of the
conservative calming columnists and
commentators and just generally social
critics across the the social Spectrum
in order to understand what's going on
in America and in the west more
generally and and sort of harvesting the
most astute critiques
um and yeah as Lionel pointed out in
that piece there are so many things
going going wrong in the country and
primarily seems to be led by members of
the cultural and economic Elite I
claimed this term a few years ago luxury
beliefs ideas and opinions that confer
status on the upper class while often
inflicting costs on the lower classes
and there are a variety of different
examples uh some that Lionel had pointed
out body positivity was one that we had
mentioned earlier The Net Zero issue
um a lot of the the
attacks and critiques on on Merit as
well all of these things do serve to
make the people who are at or near the
apex of the social ladder look
interesting it you know makes them look
uh unconventional and gives them uh it
confers a sort of status to them among
their peers uh but ultimately when these
ideas are spread throughout Society or
when they're implemented into policy
these can have detrimental effects not
only for the people in the country but
but perhaps I mean ultimately it could
potentially destabilize the world order
if we're unable to stand up to uh
villains like Putin
also I'd add that uh
this whole miasma of beliefs
is contagious
and
if I were potent I'd actually be a
little afraid of it if there's if
there's any uh
you know
previously the Soviets were trying to
corrupt the the American culture but
American culture is now capable of
corrupting other cultures and I'm afraid
that I have lived in the UK During the
period that
the UK has become infected uh it is a
kind of
illness and
and it it spreads very rapidly and
uh
and the UK is is now sick it's sick with
it
and
it's you know it's obviously it's it's
spread throughout the anglosphere and
I'm I feel confident it is spreading
into Continental Europe uh the French
like to think that they are immune to it
but they're not it's already there it's
already in pockets it's already
fashionable in universities
there's been some interesting research
lately within the U.S on uh young people
who grow up in primarily
English-speaking households versus
immigrant households in which English is
not the dominant language and what's
interesting there is that young people
who don't speak English are actually
happier and have you know score higher
in life satisfaction and are generally
less anxious and less depressed than uh
children who are raised with English in
a household and one possible
interpretation of this is that you know
when you're relentlessly exposed to
American culture English-speaking media
and so forth this actually does
demoralize you and sort of undermine
your sense of confidence and well-being
whereas if you are not consuming so much
English-speaking content and you're sort
of in your little ethnic Enclave In
Pockets that are sort of isolated from
American culture that may actually be
better for your mental health and
well-being
but but not spectated TV I should add
I'm not sure
lastly actually I lost both of you this
question lastly
um a lot of Christians uh see this
phenomenon they see progressivism as a
sort of substitute religion a lot of
non-christians starting to regard it as
a substitute religion I wonder to what
extent are you blame uh what's happening
on the decline of Christianity in the
Western Hemisphere and the decline of
sort of uh ideas of Truth
um and so on and are we running out of
the kind of moral Capital uh that
religion gave us for so long
kind of standard I don't want to accuse
you of saying things that are cliches no
it's all right it has become a cliche
actually
um that the the whole explanation for
the uh Rage of progressivism has to do
with the fact that we don't have uh
established religion uh to nearly the
degree we used to and that there is some
kind of religious need psychologically
in people that will fasten on to
something uh in lieu of
um having a a
well-defined faith they'll they'll find
something else and there's clearly
something to that
um my frustration on that point is that
I was raised uh as a presbyterian and I
didn't fancy being Presbyterian from
about the age of eight and I don't like
to think that the only alternative to
um
being
crazed with
Progressive
uh you know excessive thoughts uh is is
necessarily another set of beliefs some
of which are a little weird and depend
on stories that are I regard as a little
dubious
um why do we have to have either an
established religion
which
you know I the of the sort that I
rejected when I was a kid
or you have to go nuts politically I
mean surely surely there's a way of
believing in something and having
principles and having some faith not
uncritical but some faith in your own
society and in your own future
why do you have to believe something
stupid
necessarily is there some genetic need
to believe fairy stories of some sort I
I I I don't think so I don't I don't
think that's the only way
well at the risk of seeming delicate I
wouldn't necessarily say fairy stories
but
um Robert I think maybe what what I was
trying to get at is relativism you know
it does seem to be uh the moral Universe
post-christianity in the west and
relativism is very susceptible to the
progressivism we're talking about that
is destructive and that does make people
very unhappy and and self-harming
right well I think there was uh there I
mean there was a a brief period of
relativism in the in the 20th century uh
as as religion was on the Wane and
relativism was a useful instrument to
undermine people's belief in religion uh
but I I actually do think that to some
extent people need to have some sort of
overarching belief it doesn't I'm not
sure if it necessarily has to be
religious or political but they need
belief in something whether it's a sort
of a Civic culture or belief in some
kind of stable Traditional Values or
some kind of confidence in in the
country and in its uh its Customs but
um
in the absence of any sort of moral
order uh people you know sort of moral
entrepreneurs can step in and start to
tell people what they should be thinking
or what they should be feeling or what
they should be believing and so after a
prolonged period of relativism uh some
political activists stepped in and sort
of gave people a list of ideas that they
should be believing in a list of norms
that they should be adhering to and a
lot of people had no argument against it
and you know they were susceptible to it
and I think that is that that is at
least part of the story of what has
happened especially as as religion has
has declined
um
it's possible that we can step out of
this but we would need to have some kind
of story to replace it I don't think
that people can exist in a period of
total moral relativism
yeah the trouble with Rel with moral
relativism and and also with this
Progressive package
they both slide denialism
I mean that's what I was talking about
it the progressive package doesn't
really have any positive content and you
were talking Rob about
You Know Something to Believe In which
is not just believing what is bad
but also what is good and that's really
what's missing it's all dark and
therefore it's right next door to
nothing matters everything is
meaningless
um life is stupid we might as well be
dead I mean it's not it's not a big step
yeah yeah I mean I remember when I was
in school you know it wasn't that long
ago the 90s and the 2000s there was
still a general at least the school
system that I you know the public school
system in California that there was this
belief that uh that the founding fathers
were generally good that Abraham Lincoln
was good George Washington and you know
there of course we have to sort of
simplified maybe the fairy tale version
of the American founding but it was
still something that kids could
generally unite around and and believe
in and have confidence in and now today
now we're in the era of tear down all
the statues and Abraham Lincoln actually
wasn't such a good guy or he was
actually just as bad as the Confederacy
and so now even if you look at uh you
know patriotism or confidence in the
country those things are rapidly
declining and so naturally what's left
oh well there's the The Net Zero the
climate change campaign there's uh you
know maybe you can change your gender
maybe they're X Y and Z all of these
other sort of newfangled ideas that
people can latch onto and people can can
be awarded some kind of moral plotice
for it uh in a way that you know there's
there's no other way to so
well I think we'll wrap it up there uh
on that not tremendously cheerful uh
note but um it's absolutely fascinating
talking to you both uh and thank you
very much for coming on spectator TV
now it has been almost two decades since
newly the band hunting and it was a big
debate at the time brought some
controversy and but it appeared briefly
during the 1990s that some kind of
settlement political settlement had been
reached on Countryside Pursuits but as
will Moore who joins me now relates in
His Brilliant cup of these spectator
this week uh the the war hasn't stopped
and in fact over the last two decades
people who live in the countryside uh
feel that they their way of life has
been targeted is being targeted
um by a process we can call more set
which is why we use it more and more
it's a good one of these it catches a
lot yeah so the new work
uh and uh could you just sum up for the
viewers
um the various fronts on which this
lawfare against Countryside rural
pursues
um it's happening of course well it's
upcoming from all sorts of different
directions which is why it's very
complicated it's often very technical
and there's a lot of it and what it
essentially means is that uh without
making these Pursuits explicitly illegal
you just make it so difficult that in in
many cases it becomes almost impossible
and that's done through a variety of
methods lots of changes to licensing
often last minute often extremely
complicated changes uh just to make all
sorts of field sports
um extremely difficult and you know you
you the argument could be made you know
well what's wrong with licensing lots of
things require licensing that doesn't
mean that there's a a sort of uh covert
campaign against Field Sports but the
reason that a lot of people I spoke to
for this piece feel very differently
uh is twofold one is execution and the
other is intent so to take execution
first uh the example I start with in the
piece are these changes to the licensing
of the release of game birds in what are
known as special special protected areas
in the country and this was introduced
by defra and Natural England as a
response to the alien flu
and uh it was sort of dropped in May all
these new changes that the the left
leaving the shooting Community
completely scrabbling around trying to
to file the new paperwork for the new
licenses they're going to need in order
to release their their game boats no
consultation whatsoever so no warning
about it and there are shoots that are
sort of like I know I speak to people
with a piece who gamekeepers and so on
who shoots are facing women because of
this and it sort of comes out of nowhere
it's incredibly clunky sort of
bureaucratic uh in confidence really but
the other perhaps more important
question is one of intent so
are all these licensing changes being
brought in because uh people want some
proper management well is it because
they disapprove of activity and
um I mean the most explicit example of
this is the in the devolved government
of of Wales which is a labor government
uh Julie James is that the climate
Minister she said it is not my belief
that that a civilized society should
kill uh a creature for leisure
uh or relativity now that's expressly
saying that licensing here is not to try
and help manage the countryside it is
because they it's a moral judgment he
does do it like what it is that these
people are doing
um you know and so therefore
let's make it more difficult isn't the
problem then a more fundamental issue
which uh new labor did not really Resort
in 2004.
um which is that there are a lot of
people in Britain who think that harming
animals for far not pleasure and even if
there are ecological environmental
reasons that do so is rotten and then
there are a lot of other people on the
other side perhaps a diminishing force
in British life I mean British politics
who think that it's important part of
country life and the way people live in
the country had that tension has not
really been resolved has it no it's not
much worse uh but here's a sort of I
think it is a fundamental point when
when hunting was banned in 2004 uh where
it was classed in 2004 and came to
effect in 2005. the argument was not
about people enjoying themselves the
argument was it is cruel to the Forbes
uh the arguments now shifted it's now
this as you put it people don't know
they dare that people enjoy it so so are
we allowed to have abattoirs are we
allowed to have butchers that kill for
meat as long as they're sort of
miserable while they do it I mean you
you you're trying to we're talking about
some legal restrictions here
um it's a it's if you're trying to get
someone's intent or someone's enjoyment
out of an activity then that is a sort
of restriction on on Liberty at a
certain point it's no longer about
um cruelty to animals which I I hope
everyone can agree is is a bad thing
um well I mean I suppose it depends to
be good whether you think um killing an
animal can ever not to be correct okay
if you take if you take them some
Maximus position I actually sort of I
disagree but I respect that as a sort of
line of argument and the people who go
out to try and disrupt shoots or
whatever the sort of antes and the
saboteurs
um at least the shooting community that
and they know where they stand those
people the thing which I I uh I came
across when I was speaking to all sorts
of Games game Keepers and people
involved in in the world of field sports
is that organizations that are neutral
say they're neutral on shooting such as
Natural England and the rspb the Royal
Society for the protection of birds they
say they're neutral on shooting
um people in the shooting world do not
feel that way uh because of all the
various sort of pressures that I've I've
outlined now
whether people in Natural England or
rspb are actively anti-shooting that I
mean that that's something which I mean
we can't we can't know what I think
though is certainly true is that there
is an ideological
um goal fare between the idea of what is
conservation of the country and the
proper methods of conservation so for
Natural England and the rspb they are uh
extremely interested in rewilding and
re-wetting that and and any other form
of conservation there's something more
traditional methods used by gamekeepers
I mean big controversial one is
rotational Heather burning and uh uh
which which Natural England and rstp do
not approve of
um and so they just regardless of motive
they they just do not see eye to eye on
points such as this and uh a lot of
people
in the shooting world are very very fed
up with it and bumbly underneath it uh
as you suggested in your piece is
in a sense that um Countryside Pursuits
are purely enjoyed yeah by the other
classes and by quickly have a lot of
land and and as you said in that piece
uh yes uh there are people with lots of
Vans who like the shoots
um hunting and shooting and fishing
um but there are also a lot of other
people in Baltimore yeah that were
effective and a lot of jobs that are a
lot of jobs it's a very big part of the
rural economy the working economy and uh
you know these are people who have often
worked in Land Management
um privately for for decades they know
the land very well they often know the
best way of taking care of it
um and if there were uh if the sort of
um Cold War over filled Sports would
have become hot again
um you know these a lot of people would
be very very worried about their future
and and their and their and their jobs
and in terms of the there's some class
war element which you just mentioned um
uh I think it's particularly true of
course over over concerns about hunting
and
um uh and Labor's uh environment the
Shadow and Shadow environment Minister
said on on boxing day of last year you
know there's Boxing Day hunts and so on
and he said he he wants labor to ban
Trail hunting which is when you have
hunting with a
um a laid scent rather than any live
Quarry because he says that that he that
he believes it's often a smokes a smoke
screen for illegal hunting for where the
fox is killed
um but I think labor should think very
carefully about this because you you
when you really start legislating
against something that might happen so
if you were to collect if you were to go
out with your Hound uh and and are you
just making even the are you going to
make the that meeting itself illegal
just because they they might kill the
fox yes um it's a sort of almost guilty
till proven innocent assumption at that
point
and I suppose on the politics of it uh
this is something which the
conservatives in the past have benefited
from Vegas apparent and hostility
towards Countryside live
um country life I should say
uh and yet as you point out the base
there's there's been two decades now of
lawfare against condesa obsidians which
have been to successfully persecute in
both countries
Tories have not done anything to stop it
really have they so that's another issue
in which people who would naturally
being signed to both conservative
uh are probably thinking well what's the
point of supposedly a lot of people in
the country I think are not inherently
very politically political people
they're quite apolitical they want to
just be left alone with their Pursuits
the reason they often vote Tori is not
for any moment because they like the
Tories in fact there is huge anger
towards how the countryside has
um
being treated over the last two decades
that the thing is they do they do fear a
labor government more because they look
at the devolved government in in Wales
they look at the SMP in Scotland
obviously not labor but sort of on the
left where there's also a lot of
additional legislation and additional
ways of making things uh more difficult
and they see it as a sort of harbinger
of what might come nationally
um if there is a labor government and
it's why you know um uh Peter mandelson
who I spoke to uh for this piece and
he's he was sort of mourning against
this he's saying you know labor can't
you sort of impose its kind of City
ideas it's sort of majority City ideas
on a rural minority because it just
doesn't understand the rule the rural
way of life and labor should not be a
sort of banning finger lagging and
tolerant party if it wants to try and
win over the country William ball thank
you very much indeed thank you very much
let's turn our attention to America and
the story of the Biden family and in
particular Hunter Biden Joe Biden's son
um the international media particularly
the British media I think uh tend to
focus on the uh Trump trials and rightly
so it's a big story
um but bubbling underneath that story
um is this story of Hunter Biden
um I'm joined Now by Ben schreckinger
who is author of the bidens uh inside
the first family's 50-year rise to power
he also works for Politico Ben I'm very
glad that uh we've got to talk to you
because quite often when we hear
Americans talking about the hunter Biden
story and they are obviously parted and
obviously Republicans or Trump
supporters who are banging on about
um Hunter Biden and the Biden Crown
crime family and so on
um and as a result I suspect collect
the significance of this story has
perhaps been lost and I don't know about
your own baltics I don't want to get
into that
um but you've approached this story as a
reporter in your book and in your work
um and I think it's I'd say it is a very
interesting and potentially extremely
significant story
yeah absolutely
um obviously during the 2020 campaign
especially uh
Democrats really focused on uh Rudy
giuliani's attempts to make hay out of
Hunter Biden's business dealings uh
contacts he had with people affiliated
with Russian intelligence all that and
that was very much the impression that
people on the left side here in the
states had of this story that it was
sort of uh uh ginned up out of nothing
by Donald Trump cronies uh on the right
obviously this has been a very big story
and a very big Focus for years and years
um I I do think now especially in recent
months uh with Hunter Biden entering
this guilty plea uh with House
Republicans uh getting testimony from a
number of people uh including a couple
of IRS agents involved in the case who
said there were irregularities it's
becoming a little bit less of a purely
partisan
um lens that people are bringing to this
I think the Press here in the U.S
outside of the conservative press has
been paying more attention to this uh in
recent months and I think that's only
going to continue as long as Joe Biden
is a candidate for president tell us a
little bit about that plea deal Ben
because uh it seems to me there are
different stories here there's the
hunter plea deal which relates to a a
case about a minor gun misdemeanor which
appeared to be letting him off the hook
for various misdemeanors
um and a lot of Republicans were very
angry about that at the time when it
happened just over a month ago and then
there's the ongoing investigation into
his past and business dealings and that
might bring in Joe Biden how are those
two stories developing and explain a
little bit more please
sure yeah it's very messy and the status
especially of the Justice Department
investigation is uh up in the air at
this point uh two weeks ago there was a
hearing in Delaware uh Hunter Biden was
gonna plea plead guilty to some tax
crimes uh and get a what's called a
pre-trial diversion on a gun charge
um that deal was sort of thrown back to
the drawing board by the judge uh there
appeared to be a lack of a meeting of
the minds between Hunter Biden's side
and prosecutors over what that deal
meant Hunter Biden's side believed and
was telling people that this uh plea
deal would signal the end of justice
department investigations into Hunter
Biden interest in Hunter Biden uh but
prosecutors said well actually
investigations into Hunter Biden remain
ongoing they wouldn't say what those
investigations pertain to and there was
disagreement about whether this plea
deal would essentially end those
investigations or not or perhaps it's
just one investigation
um so the judge said look you need to go
back to the drawing board uh there was
also issues about
um the way in which it was structured
whether it was being structured and
would prevent the judge from uh being
able to provide the oversight that you
wanted uh so we should find out soon uh
whether or not they're able to to piece
that uh plea deal back together uh and
then in the meantime separate from that
House Republicans are pursuing their own
investigations of Hunter Biden uh
obviously they're very focused on trying
to connect what Hunter's been doing to
his father his father's office
they've had a a parade of witnesses come
forward including business partners of
Hunter Biden a couple of IRS
investigators involved on in that tax uh
tax case that Hunter's trying to tie up
right now uh
and so all indications that is that
they're going to be keeping this uh
front and center in their agenda uh for
the foreseeable future as long as Joe
Biden is running for president and Kevin
mcaulfe the Republican house Speaker has
suggested uh there might be a
trial into impeachment proceedings
and that's not the same as an
impeachment as I understand it but uh
that that could happen quite soon
um and the White House keeps saying
um that this is a an evidence-free uh
wild goose chase and and dismissing it
quite
um aggressively
um however it's not really is it I mean
you've written this book about the Biden
family
and there is no denying that there are
lots of uh legitimate areas of concern
about
um how the Biden family operated and it
seems to me you had Hunter Biden and Joe
Biden's brother James or Jim uh
operating the business side of the Biden
family operation while uh Joe and uh
Hunter's brother Bo who sadly died uh
were very much in the political field
um to what extent do you think it was a
family operation a family grift if you
like
yeah well I think uh it's very queer
that this is a family that's very close
on an interpersonal level and it's also
clear that uh the Biden family uh has
been integral uh over the decades to Joe
Biden's political operation political
life as advisors as the people literally
running campaigns including his sister
Valerie who's a campaign manager for uh
for several of the Senate campaigns uh
his brother James uh was the chief
fundraiser on his first Senate campaign
uh and then after that you do have this
pattern where various members of the
Biden family engage in business deals uh
that are raising questions going back to
the 1970s in the papers about whether
they're getting favorable terms on loans
for example because of who their brother
is
um whether they're invoking there are
certainly allegations of business
partners uh some of them made in in
court proceedings that they invoke their
political Cloud as reasons that they
would be able to land contracts land
business from people like way labor
union leaders
um
and what it remains unclear uh is how
much Joe knew about this he said he's
never discussed uh his family's business
dealings with them uh you've had people
uh involved in those business dealings
saying well that's not quite true Tony
babulinski has come forward and said I
at least in general terms uh discuss
some some business dealings in China
with Joe Biden
um that I was engaging in with Hunter
and James Biden
um
you know there's there's not evidence uh
there's not you know anything like a
Smoking Gun that Joe Biden has taken in
official action uh because of or at the
behest of a business partner of his
relatives
um
but certainly there are questions about
uh
how much he should have known whether he
should have gone further in discouraging
this uh whether he should be publicly
disavowing uh some of these uh deals
that Hunters engaged in and so this is
an issue that does not seem like it's
going away for him and the latest big
twist in the story is the testimony
Congressional testimony or Devin Archer
who is a business partner of Hunter
Biden who has said that uh Joe Biden
would be on as many as 20 I think calls
uh Business Schools Hunter Biden was
making with uh various often foreign
people that he was doing business
dealings with
um and Joe Biden was vice president at
the time
uh and therefore uh even if he didn't
say anything even if there's no evidence
of him saying anything that might have
been inappropriate the very fact that he
was on those calls is pretty significant
to sit not and I think no amount of kind
of democratic poo pooing of it can can
make that go away
yeah it certainly shows that uh 100
Biden's intention uh was to flaunt his
access to his father uh to make him look
like an attractive business partner
often uh from people who were seeking a
favorable reception in Washington DC
um
another part of Devon Archer's testimony
that stuck that stuck out to me uh
related to a a dinner in 2015 at Cafe
Milano which is a big DC Gathering Spot
in an Italian restaurant in Georgetown
uh where 100 Biden's laptop materials
first leaked uh there was a barisma
executive Autumn bazarski uh emailing
around the time of this dinner to say
hey Hunter it was great to meet your
father thank you so much something along
those lines uh and there was emails
about this dinner in in which uh
pozarski was on the guest list there's
talk about getting Joe Biden there
um and it's been a whole Saga
establishing whether or not uh those two
cross paths as the these emails
suggested uh the White House has said no
meeting took place uh other people at
the meeting have come forward at this
dinner and said we don't have any
recollection of pazarsky being there uh
Devin Archer testified under oath that
uh yes bizarski was at this dinner as
well uh that what these emails suggest
happened didn't in fact happen uh and so
there are issues like this uh where uh
we're not getting uh consistent answers
uh uh from the White House for example
uh answers that are consistent with what
other people are saying and what these
emails are showing about the extent of
intermingling of Joe Biden with Hunter
Biden's business partners when he was
vice president
and it looks as the Republicans are
pushing towards uh an impeachment
um do you think that will happen
I I hate to make predictions about the
future uh
I would not be shocked if they followed
through on this I would be shocked if uh
Joe Biden were impeached removed by the
Democrat controlled Senate uh that seems
very unlikely but this is another tool
that House Republicans uh have to to
keep the focus on this keep the
spotlight on this uh and keep the
spotlight off of Donald Trump's trials
uh I spent and forgive me if I'm
peddling a trumpist talking point but I
suppose one Theory might be that if
impeachment were to come up the a
Democratic Senate might actually impeach
Biden if by the time of the next
election uh his uh public performances
have become so bad uh he is getting very
old that there there is a desire among
the Democratic party
um to see him gone and that the hunter
story might be a good pretext for doing
that
well I have not heard that theory
floated it's intriguing
um I do think that there are uh a lot of
measures short of supporting a
conviction and an impeachment proceeding
that that members of a
of a president's party would have uh it
says nudge them aside if they wanted to
uh so I personally doubt that it would
come to that
um but you know we're a long way away
from election day and there's a lot of
uh you know a lot of moving pieces uh
and so fireworks of some sort uh
in this election are almost guaranteed
then we'll leave it there but thank you
very much for joining us
now let's talk about e-bikes or
electronic bicycles which seem to be a
divisive topic Peter Hitchens has
written a tippity forthright piece in
the magazine this week about how much he
dislikes them uh and I'm joined by him
now hello Peter good morning I'm also
joined by Henry down the line Henry from
the financial times Henry Mance uh who
is a fan a supporter of e-bikes
um Peter I'll start with you because you
wrote the piece you're an Enthusiast for
cycling uh as you say in the piece but
you really don't like ebike yes they're
a fraud they look they look like bikes
they make people think that they're
riding bikes and they they also are
allowed into the cycle lens which it
took Decades of campaigning to get in
which is supposed to be free of Motor
Vehicles and they are Motor Vehicles
they're bike-shaped objects but they're
actually motorbikes and many of them can
go extremely fast and many of them are
very heavy indeed and so the whole
battle people which took which I took
part in which took past 40 years to get
special spaces on the roads for for
human-powered lightweight silent clean
bicycles has now been tossed to one side
so these horrible things can go whizzing
and whining along along bike tracks and
excessive speeds and we aren't safe
anymore and you think people should have
a license to to write well they are they
are motor vehicles and all Motor
Vehicles in this country until very
recently uh until I think chaps was it
was the sexual estate for transport had
to had to be ridden by people who were
licensed and now this has been dropped
both for e-bikes and for their hideous
cousins the e-scooter with results which
I think will carry on bothering us for
many years to come and people will
wonder in times to come why was so
stupid as to make these things legal and
to allow people to ride them without any
serious qualification I have a
motorcycle license uh and it's quite a
hard thing to get and they're actually
quite hard things to write and I think
if you're going to ride motorbike you
should you should learn how to do it and
go to get a license have you have you
been on an eBay have you tried it no
they give you Red Mist as soon as I see
them I can't see any points in them uh
if I once if I wanted to use Motor
Vehicles I would but I deliberately gave
up those Vehicles as far as I could many
years ago and why should I start doing
so because someone's produced a motor
vehicle that looks like a bicycle and
isn't
Henry you are mentioned in this piece uh
I think you're described uh as uh being
typical of Metropolitan trendys who ride
e-bikes uh how do you respond to this
charge
I mean I take it as a huge compliment
Freddie and um rarely but I I think
Peter's problem is that he's too young
and uh and fit and uh and full of energy
and he doesn't quite appreciate the you
know the role that e-bikes can play it's
actually quite nice to discuss this
topic because you say it's very divisive
but it's nice to discuss it with someone
with like Peter who who gets the
principle and who is on board with
changing changing what our cities look
like rather than someone who who just
wants to continue throwing more cars
down the same streets which uh I think
has had lots of uh bad effects and and
uh really whether you're on the left or
the right there should be a good case
for uh cycling and active active travel
being a bigger part than the more SUVs
Etc but I think
um I'm Peter's wrong to say that these
are basically motorbikes the real
difference with knee bikers you still
have to Pedal to get any support from
the motor so you can't just sit on it
and whiz up a hill
um but uh and and these bikes although
they're a bit sturdier than the pedal
bike you might be used to they're not a
motorbike right yeah a line bike which
people will see around London weighs
about 35 kilograms a motorbike would be
10 times that and you know you know a
Volkswagen Golf is is over a ton so
really these things do still belong in
the segregated cycle Lane and what I
think they really do is open up cycling
to a whole range of people who don't
have Peter's energy who live on a hill
you know London is not Amsterdam
um you know we can't we can't change the
geography we need to get more people
cycling and offering them a bit of
assistance making it a bit less hard
work is one way of doing that
except that it isn't you may have to
actually turn the pedals and to get an
eBay to go uphill but you're not doing
what I'm doing when I go uphill I often
have to stand on the pedals to go uphill
but it I know that it's extremely
valuable exercise it's free for you to
call me young I am in fact nearly 72 but
the the truth is that if I am fit that
it's because I have been you doing the
hard business of peddling a powerless
bicycle for many years often uphill and
if people want Fitness from both schools
they have to do that and there's no
point to taking any any ee bicycle I'm
overtaken by by them all the time by
people who obviously haven't been as
I've been cycling for decades uh who
just get on them and can achieve speeds
without any real serious effort it takes
me a really major effort to get to they
are not in even remotely comparable in
their ability to provide exercise to to
proper bicycles and they may not be as
heavy as motorbikes I agree with you
about that but that the the ordinary
ones the ones constantly picking up from
where they're dumped on the pavement
we're two and a half times as much as an
ordinary bicycle and the the great big
cargo machines can be about five times
as much and these are really are very
powerful motor vehicles but they are
motorbikes because they are bicycles
which have a motor they're possibly more
comparable to the things which were
actually called mopeds probably 40 or 50
years ago the word is now widely misused
and there were there were motor assisted
bicycles but you had to have a license
for those and again you could you had to
Pedal them but the pedals did a little
bit but the most it did most of it and
let's not pretend the motor is doing
most of the work without the most of the
things would be simply too heavy to ride
what I sense is I think when anesthesia
came along in the 19th century there
were some doctors who who opposed it on
the basis that you know people should
suffer and it was a good idea to to get
a sense of their pain that was helpful
for the medical process uh I think some
of that may still be around in in the
way we approach childbirth but um uh and
that's kind of the one of the attitude
that I see seeping through from some uh
you know traditional cyclists towards
ebike the idea that cycling should be a
very active thing it should you know it
should be hard on a rainy day it should
be hard to go up a hill this will get
you fit and the problem is that a lot of
people just haven't warmed to that I
mean I'm very happy to go out on a
normal bike as well as an e-bike I enjoy
it but a lot a lot of people just
haven't wanted to do that they've got in
their cars instead and so how do we get
them out of their cars we offer them a
slightly easier so I think it's better
well you offer you there's many ways of
getting people out of cars the principal
one which of course the Swiss is very
good that's just providing first-rate
public transport that gets people out of
their cars you're never going to get an
awful lot of people immediately start
cycling what a lot of people don't
realize is I think the the Dutch until
about the late 50s and early 60s were
just as calm out as we were in their
cities with just as car can just they
took an actual decision as a government
and a people to turn away from this and
to promote cycling and it's taken many
many years to get to where they are now
and of course they have the curse of the
e-bike too which is strongly opposed by
many Dutch cyclists because they don't
want these things in cycle days but the
truth is that it would it will take a
long time I'm not it's nice to do with
anesthetic and that's one of the reasons
I ride a motorbike anymore is that I I
had a very bad accident on one and I I
was lined by the roadside in
considerable pain I was very glad when I
got out of static it's not remotely
comparable uh to the to the minor
discomfort you feel when you peddle a
bicycle uphill as silly a non-comparison
so let's let's not have it people it's
true that cycling is a bit difficult and
quite a lot of people find things that
are a bit difficult uh too hard to do
well okay let them if they if they want
to ride Motor Vehicles right on the road
I don't mind if they want to write these
things about on the road it's if they
come whizzing Along on cycle tracks and
you're supposed to go at 15 miles an
hour and they're supposed to be governed
by little widgets which don't let them
go any faster but it's horribly widely
known that these things couldn't be
tweaked and you can you can go far
faster than that and everybody knows
that they do and so here you have on
cycle lens objects which look like
bicycles tearing by perhaps 30 even 35
40 miles an hour very heavy if they hit
you you'll be very badly hurt and the
whole purpose of the cycle will end to
segregate the vulnerable cyclists the
human a human frame on a small
lightweight machine from heavy traffic
has been undermined in a matter of I
think two years it's gone from from
Bliss being on cycle layers in London
being an absolute nightmare is Henry
it's a problem not just what's going on
the lanes but the Clutter uh outside the
spectator's office at the moment there
are three human forests which is one of
the rental uh systems if you like of
e-bikes in London uh and that's what
people object to the most I suppose
question applies to both of you is that
they do clutter up Pavements uh there
are e-bikes everywhere and there are
also e-scooters everywhere
um is that the is that a problem do you
think
yeah yeah and I think that we should
hunt very hard for the three spectator
journalists who have left those bikes
outside uh outside the office
um but no I I think I think you're right
and I think when these new technologies
come along they do bring teething
troubles I mean do you remember when
mobile phones came along and everybody
was talking very loudly in train
carriages and it seemed like our future
would be a complete hell of listening to
other people's mobile phone
conversations and we sort of developed
Norms around that and anyone everyone
texts now anyway so no one no one ever
picks up the phone
um and I I do think that some of the
complaints around e-bikes are are things
that we could manage a bit better in in
Paris and Peter knows the case very well
but in Paris they've just had a
referendum
um on Banning not e-scooters but
e-scooter rentals on the basis that you
know people who own their own e-scooter
they tend to to you know be fairly
responsible with it and they you know
stick to the rules and they don't have
two or three people going on the same
scooter and they don't leave it lying
around on the pavement but people who
rent one from company like lime they
they may be a bit more Carefree about it
and a bit sort of uh not such good
citizens and I think the Clutter is a
real problem if you're in a if you're in
a wheelchair or if you're trying to uh
just walk down a pavement
um then then they're a nuisance so you
know finding a way in which there's
designated parking areas and people have
to pay very high fees if they don't
leave it in those parking areas that
seems to me the way forward but it
doesn't seem to be an insoluble problem
that you should throw out e-bikes
altogether well why were they licensed
in the first place they would they were
completely illegal until about recently
and suddenly there's an explosion of
them uh there's another question of
throwing them out the the real argument
is why why we took this step which is
still in my view reversible and whether
it was wise to do it's not just I have
to say on cycle layers that these things
would be found I was quite a broken
house your wonderful officers a few
months ago and I was nearly sent to my
reward by any bike which must have been
doing 30 miles an hour along the
pavement in the city of London and and
the the unfortunately am I I still have
enough obsessive hearing to notice it
coming but it was very close around the
thing and that's the second time in my
life that I've come close to being
erased by by anybody they are dangerous
and they as I say they are not properly
licensed they're not properly regulated
anything of this level of danger in any
other area of life would be regulated
and so it's licensing these things are
just allowed out everywhere and they are
growing in number every day there are
more of them and if if nobody does
anything about it soon we are going to
regress it and and here I am just just
making this point and also trying to get
a cycling campaigners who have accepted
them in a rather open mouth way to see
there's a huge difference between a
human pads silent machine and a heavy a
heavyweight motorbike capable of 30 or
40 miles an hour and they shouldn't
allow them to be mixed up and they
shouldn't be allowed on cycle lens and
they also shouldn't be allowed on
payments one other thing which we need
to do of course is to is to introduce a
fantastic idea in this country which I I
think other countries have it's just
called a police force you hire people to
enforce the law and you make them walk
around the streets stopping people who
break the law we don't have one of these
uh at least if we have I haven't seen
any trace of it but if you have one of
those then we could also sort this thing
out on that emphatic note
as you agree with you on on that that
you know where is the enforcement where
is the enforcement of bad driving
everywhere but let me give you an
example I mean I have a normal bike
which I will take occasionally into the
office but I'll take around town and
then if I want to go somewhere with my
kids then I put them on the back of a
cargo bike they get strapped in and it's
only possible let's not get started on
cargo bikes let's not do that that's a
whole nother to do we'll do that in the
next uh the next Edition but Henry and
Peter thank you very much uh for coming
on spectator TV
um it's an enjoyable debate
now let's talk about sourdough uh Judy
bindel routes is here I'm a much loved
spectator contributor uh has written a
piece and it's on our website called
just saying no to sourdough and the
stand first is put it in the bin and
this piece Has Gone Bananas on the
internet I think it said it might be
what our most read piece of the year so
far uh and it's a vicious attack really
on sourdough bread
um let's start with the obvious question
what's your problem with sourdough
everything
look first of all I'm delighted that
it's doing so well but sometimes I put
huge amounts of time and effort Blood
Sweat and Tears writing about awful
violence against women and girls
terrible unsolved crimes
and sourdough does better than that yeah
I'm going to become a food Christian you
did better than knowledge about that
huge amount but this is actually quite
funny because it's been brewing in my
head for a long time and I've been
kicking off about it with my friends in
restaurants even in bakeries high-end
bakeries where I live in crush on Crouch
end where everywhere I look there's two
sourdough people asking for sourdough
restaurants with different cuisines
all serving it and so my problem with
sourdough twofold first I don't like its
taste or Texture which is pretty kind of
basic
and secondly it's become a little bit
like I suppose 1986 in East Berlin
before the Wall came down where you were
queuing for bread and there was one type
of bread and that was it this is East
Berlin in 1986. yeah it's colonized the
entire bread world
I'm old enough to remember the kiwi
fruit Fad in the 1980s every single dish
that you
ordered in every restaurant had a slice
of this Abomination on top of it
ugly it tasted vile and it was just seen
as something that you couldn't serve a
meal without and then all of a sudden it
dropped off the radar and everybody went
back to rightly so hating kiwi fruit
with sourdough it was different because
obviously it was going to be a type of
bread that some people would really like
it suits their palate it suits why and
how they eat bread
but during lockdown and there was a big
yeast shortage in 2020
the recipe went viral around all of
these bored people working from home or
furloughed and had too much time in
their hands and it was guess what you
can make this type of bread the type of
bread that you get in these Posh very
upper middle class you know North London
bakeries without yeast so that then did
the rounds on Instagram and people were
no longer posting their photographs of
their holidays and their meals out in
restaurants and their nights stoshes in
bars and so all of a sudden we started
to see these really ugly pictures of
over baked crusted bread with massive
cracks in them and people holding them
out like some burned offering and even
bringing them around and leaving them on
the doorstep because of course we
couldn't you know social distancing I
opened my door once and there was a loaf
of bread and a text message from a
friend saying thought you'd like this
and I thought well okay I've never liked
this stuff but how kind of her to do
that yeah so I tried to eat it with soup
no chance because it's so hard and the
crust is so uncompromising that you can
dip it in soup the soup just falls off
it back into the bowl they won't absorb
it so I tried to dip it in a bit of
olive oil and had it with
some snacks that wouldn't work because
it won't absorb the olive oil and of
course trying to make a sandwich with it
you would honestly need a jaw this size
and you would be chewing it forever and
then you'd need to go to the dentist and
it was locked down and there were no
dentists open so I thought maybe after
lockdown it will start to get
unpopular made of people that have had
enough it's actually got even more
stratospherically
yes popular amongst people Wally well I
think I could answer that question a
little bit uh because your piece heard
my feelings slightly because I am as you
would put it a a bread bro I'm a bread
but you don't look like want to be fair
I've never tried to be a kind of hipster
or anything like that but I what
happened is a few months ago
I went to a friend's house and we had
some bread in the morning uh and I said
the street delicious and she said oh
I'll give you some my starter which as
you notice he said it's the salesman
culture yeah uh so she gave me some and
I put it in the cart and I didn't really
think I was going to actually use it but
just to do but then quite bored that
evening I decided to give it a go and I
realized it's actually incredibly easy
and you get a lot of compliments to
doing something that's incredibly easy
uh and I also think looking after the
mother of the starter is a bit like
gardening it has its own pleasure
because he'll sort of basically not
you're looking after a live culture but
anyway as a result I did I've actually
brought because I do bring it into the
office
[Music]
to make
um prepared earlier and so I'm not sure
that TV before but here is uh it's not
been very uh nice but here's here's some
sourdough breaths that I've made
uh this is I'm here under false
pretenses I was not told that this was
part of my punishment and did you want
butter I will try a little bit about
because that's the only way that it
might actually slip down in yeah okay
just have a taste I will have a taste
because you didn't complain about how
hard brother crossed it well you know
the thing is that what I found was when
I was eating sourdough is that the taste
of blood doesn't really go well with
bread and that's what was happening I
actually had a mouse injury thank you
very much I had a mouse injury
government you actually have cut here on
My Lip from trying to chew a bit of
sourdough that a collie bought me yes
thinking that I would like it because
everyone else does okay
eight days
you've changed your line completely I
can't wait for the reaction
it's very nice
great
this is like Paul Hollywood reviewing um
a cake
it's very nice but no disrespect mum
taken this is very different
from the high-end Bakery sort
better of course thank you
where you have to take a chisel to get
through to it wear your bread knife
buckles yes and where you cannot
possibly to
the the contents of that in any fewer
than say 10 solid minutes and two lost
fillings so that I would just say is a
nice loaf of bread why can't they all
make it like yours there we get it maybe
I should head in a bakery
that I think that they want the
masochistic see that that's why I think
the machismo comes in I think that they
want the massive thick heavy dark
cracked crust I think they want the huge
dents insides because it's you know it's
a bit like the kind of massive rib eye
steaks that some men get really into
yeah you see them in steakhouses where
they order the huge 900 gram piece of
steak with a huge bone going through it
and they're chewing away for hours and
drinking a red wine you could slice in
half I think that's part of that eating
culture is that a streak of Miss Andrea
here and that it's it's things that men
tend to fixate without question I mean
look yeah like brewing beer for instance
and you're right that men got obsessed
with well a lot of men together emphasis
for making beer and uh there was this a
big fan for hoppy bit you know lots and
hops in a bit and it took it's such an
extreme yeah uh that sun beer was just
revolting I think I say in the article
that it's a bit like the do dude Bros
you really are not one of those that's
all you're much nicer you have a much
tidier appearance than these guys they
use beard oil and they have man buns and
they look like 18th century Carpenters
right these men and they also like the
really extreme chili infused cocktails
they're like kimchi and fermented stuff
like fermented to next door and back
yeah so they go in for these extremities
you're absolutely right and I think
that's how sourdough has become
parody of itself that to me tastes like
a nice slice of Greek country bread
you know it's it's not
what to be honest it's not sour yeah
well maybe I'm doable but thank you very
much for trying it and to be so polite
you can go and throw up there it's my
pleasure it's a nice tasty piece of
bread
on that delicious note I think we'll end
at spectator TV for this week thank you
very much indeed for watching don't
forget to subscribe to the YouTube
channel do that by clicking that
subscribe button and then the Bell icon
and we'll see you again next week
[Music]
thank you